Wir wollen mal wieder auf die 2. Liga der Männer blicken und da haben wir euch heute eine tolle Runde mitgebracht. Wir werden sprechen über Hertha BSC, über Hannover 96 und über Holstein Kiel und das Ganze tun wir mit Pike, mit Ansgar Löcke und mit Jan Müller-Reichenwallner. Und genau jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Und das an Zunung. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Leute, ich sag's euch, wie es ist. Ich hab Bock. Wir werden sprechen über die 2. Liga. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, was wir heute alles so aufdecken werden. Aber erstmal begrüße ich nochmal meine Runde bei mir. Zum einen natürlich Pike ist dabei von 1912 FM. Servus, Pike. Schön, dass du da bist. Ansgar Löcke ist hier von Niemals weiter – nein, Moment mal. Wie heißt dein aktuelles Format, Ansgar, wo man dich hören kann?
Vorne ist – Gelegentlich noch bei Vorwärts nach weit.
Vorwärts nach weit. Es tut mir leid. Das ist jetzt natürlich – Aber da siehst du mal, wie schludrig ich werde, wenn jemand so oft im Rasenfunk ist, dann bereite ich mich offensichtlich gar nicht mehr vor. Aber trotzdem schön, dass du da bist. Und wie einstmals haben wir im Vorgespräch mit Kindertalk begonnen. Das muss offenbar so sein, im Rasenfunk. Und wir haben aber auch einen Neuling heute hier, aber neu ist er nur für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich kenne ihn schon ganz lange. Jan ist hier und als Neuling gebührt dir natürlich die Ehre, nicht nur hallo zu sagen, sondern du darfst auch kurz sagen, wo man dich finden und hören kann. Hi Jan.
Man findet mich gelegentlich noch beim DMTF Podcast, ein englischer Hertha-Podcast, der momentan etwas daran leidet, dass wir seit Corona uns nicht mehr so oft sehen. Mit den Herren aus England und Kanada.
Wir wollen über die 2. Liga sprechen und die erste Frage ist ja traditionell in diesen Sendungen. Und Pike darf mal beginnen, weil er droht am obersten in der Tabelle. Was ist denn gerade so wichtig zu wissen? Was ist gerade so die Lage der Liga?
Ja, also einerseits, dass St. Pauli ganz gut vorweg marschiert. Trotzdem ein kleiner Ausrutscher gegen Schalke, aber ich glaube, den konnten sie dann ganz gut verkraften. Und ja, dass jetzt auch der Abstiegskampf nochmal spannend wird irgendwie. Osnabrück hat angefangen, Punkte zu holen gegen Hannover und Hamburg. Jetzt dann auch wieder ein kleiner Ausrutscher, aber trotzdem. Also ja, man sagt ja so schön, die stärkste 2. Liga, die es jemals gab und jeder kann jeden schlagen und das wird auch irgendwie jedes Wochenende wieder bewiesen. Also auch, wenn man sich so die Verfolge anguckt, so aufsteigen will gefühlt auch keiner, alle straucheln da irgendwie mal. Und wenn irgendwer die Chance hat, dann mal nach vorne zu preschen, nutzt er sie auch nicht. Also ich war schon ganz erstaunt, dass wir jetzt mal so eine kleine Vorlage genutzt haben gegen Karlsruhe. Aber ansonsten, ja, es gibt wenig graues Mittelfeld in der Liga.
Aber wirklich, ich habe neulich eine Grafik gesehen. Vom 1. bis zum 18. Platz können sämtliche Teams noch auf allen Plätzen landen, rechnerisch gesehen am Ende der Saison. Das ist natürlich hart für einen Neuligen wie Jan, aber so ein alter Zweitliga-Hase wie Ansgar, den macht das nicht mehr nervös. Du hast es schon tausendmal erlebt. Du kannst uns jetzt vom Krieg erzählen, wie wird alles enden oder ist es alles gar nicht so spannend gerade für dich?
Liga ist halt wie die 2. Liga so ist und wir machen da munter genauso aktuell so mit. Wir kennen das die letzten Jahre, gewinnt mal drei Spiele und denkt, man ist ganz oben mit dabei, dann sind vier Spiele wieder ohne Sieg und man verteufelt alles in Grund und Boden. Ich glaube, da ist Hannover in einer Riegel mit 12 bis 14 Mannschaften der Liga, die die Saison schon erlebt haben und genau dieselben Fragen sich stellen, nur dass wir halt irgendwie zehn Punkte mehr haben als andere, in den letzten Saisons waren wir immer so zehn Punkte schlechter als der aktuelle Stand oder fünf, aber ja, dieses Verfolger-Duell ist wirklich bezeichnet für die zweite Liga, dass man so ein bis anderthalb souveräne Vereine oben hat und der Rest fällt Jahr für Jahr auf dieselben Sachen neu rein, also ob es Spiele gegen tiefstehende Aufsteiger ist oder ja, dumme Platzweise je nachdem, also wie du sagst, alles schon mal gehabt. Wir freuen uns alle sehr, dass andere das auch mal erleben können.
Aber es fallen ja nicht nur die Vereine drauf rein, ich kann mich an einen Moderator hier im Rasenfunk erinnern, der gesagt hat, ach ja, Braunschweig und Osnabrück, die sind ja weg, ja, Pustekuchen, also er hätte Rostock jetzt nicht gewonnen gegen Braunschweig, ein Punkt sind die gerade vor, Relegationsplatz versus Abstiegsplatz und Osnabrück mit sieben Punkten jetzt auch auf einmal wieder in Reichweite. Jan, was macht dieses ganze emotionale Chaos mit dir und was ist für dich gerade neben Hertha natürlich das Interessanteste an der Liga?
Für mich ist es interessant, dass Schalke mit einem Sieg am Sonntag gegen uns ein Punkt hinter uns auf einmal wäre.
Hm, also sprich bei dir regiert die nackte Angst.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich finde es eigentlich sehr angenehm in der 2. Liga. Wenn es finanziell nicht so ein Problem wäre, würde ich da auch erstmal gerne bleiben.
Ehrlich? Warum denn das?
Es ist viel mehr Spaß. Also ich habe viel mehr das Gefühl, dass alles viel mehr Spaß macht. Wenn ich so Stadien bin voller, ist mehr los.
Ansgar, was glaubst du, wie viele Jahre lang wird ihm das noch Spaß machen? Wann ist es bei dir gekippt?
Ach, wir hatten ja ein paar lustige Jahre, wo es mal losging. Also ich sage mal, es gab dann schon ein, zwei Jahre, wo es dann wirklich, wirklich gruselig wurde. Aber es kann eine Zeit lang Spaß machen. Gut, ich sage mal, mit so einem riesengroßen Stadion wie der Hertha ist das dann natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Baustelle. Ich meine, wir haben schon ein großes Stadion. Wenn mal Schalke vorbeikommt, wenn mal Magdeburg vorbeikommt, Hertha macht das auch ganz gut. Aber wenn dann ständig sie kleinen Vereine nur 40 Leute mitbringen, das passiert diese Saison zum Glück nicht ganz so oft, weil die ganzen kleinen Vereine ja oben sind oder ganz unten. Aber das ändert sich ja auch wieder. Man sollte sich nicht zu sehr täuschen lassen von dem schönen Amtier hinter der zweiten Liga. Generell ist es schon schön, wieder hochzukommen. Sind sich ja auch bei Hannover alleinig. Nur wann? Das ist dann immer das Gewürfel.
Ja, in welcher Dekade das jetzt klappen wird, da lassen wir uns einfach überraschen. Jan, ich glaube, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Ja, zum Wiederaufstieg. Da hatte ja Tom Herrich, der Geschäftsführer, vor kurzem sich geäußert, dass ein Aufstieg 2025 alternativlos sei.
Na, da ist ja dann gar kein Druck.
Bei uns ja auch.
Ach so, bei euch auch.
Ja, wir laufen ja mitten im Dreijahresplan.
Ach ja, stimmt. Genau, es gab den Leiteln, die Aufstiegsleiteln gab es da quasi, den Dreijahresplan. Richtig. Pike, was ist bei euch der Plan? Habt ihr einen Elfjahresplan?
Also unser Fangesang sagt, 2045 holen wir die Meisterschaft und den Bokal. Wenn wir das schaffen, sind wir mit einem guten Zeitplan.
Hä, machen bei euch die Fangesänge, die Marketingagenturen von Hertha?
Bei uns ist jedes Jahr etablieren in der 2. Liga. Das ist jedes Jahr das Motto.
Das ist das Heidenheim-Motto und auf einmal ist man dann doch in Liga 1.
Aber wirklich, ja. Jan hält es gar nicht aus.
Ich habe lustigerweise nochmal in einen Podcast von Pike rein gehört, die letzte Folge, die sie gemacht haben. Und da sprachen sie so vom Aufstieg, als wäre es eine völlig ferne Sache, die sie niemals glauben würden.
Wir glauben es immer noch nicht. Also als deutschen Key-Fan ist man auch viel Leid gewohnt. Also mal schauen.
Naja, aber bis zur Meisterschaft 2045 habt ihr ja dann noch 20 Jahre, euch in der ersten Liga zu etablieren.
Das sollten wir dann schaffen, ja.
Das wird dann der Augsburger Weg. Aber ich finde es ganz interessant, dass wir jetzt schon so lange über die zweite Liga gesprochen haben. Und der Name Steffen Baumgart noch nicht gefallen ist. Also bevor wir reingehen in unsere Segmente, müssen wir da, finde ich, schon kurz drüber sprechen. Jan, hättest du – also ich bin ehrlich. Ich dachte, Steffen Baumgart, HSV, okay, wenn es irgendjemand schafft, dann Kraft seiner eigenen Stimmbänder, Stimmblippen, dann Steffen Baumgart, irgendwie den HSV nach oben zu zerren. Jetzt zwei Niederlagen in Folge. Wie blickst du auf das, was da beim HSV gerade passiert?
Mit der distanzierten Belustigung, dass ich damit nichts zu tun habe. Und ich denke an meinen armen Freund, der mir jedes Frühjahr immer wieder schreibt, der als Hamburger sehr leidet, dass es natürlich wieder das Gleiche war. Und wahrscheinlich wird es nicht so klappen. Aber so viel an Fehler gemacht, darf man nicht sagen. Auf jeden Fall verpufft der Effekt, kann man sagen.
Ich habe auch gelesen, dass Steffen Baumgart jetzt viel mehr flanken lässt und gesagt hat, es ist noch zu wenig, also der HSV. Er möchte nicht, dass ich ihn gucke, offenbar. Also bin ich jetzt der Einzige in der Runde, der dachte, das würde gut passen? Nee, oder?
Nee, also ich hätte gedacht, dass zumindest dieser Motivationspunkt bei ihm, dass das echt noch mal fruchtet beim HSV, weil ich glaube, den Tim-Walter-Ball in kürzester Zeit aus dem HSV rauszukriegen, ist glaube ich nicht machbar. Aber so Motivation und dieses Kopfproblem, was der HSV gefühlt ja am Ende jeder Saison, der doch hat, dass Baumgart das eigentlich in den Griff bekommt, bisher ist es noch nicht gelungen, aber könnte noch was werden, aber wird schwierig.
Ich finde es lustig, dass er jetzt gelandet ist. Ich glaube, seit über einem Jahr hat die hannoverische Lokalpresse so eine leichte Obsession mit Baumgart. Seit wir den ja mal uns theoretisch damals angelacht haben, bevor er nach Köln ging, wir mal kurz angefragt haben, er ich glaube lachend auflegte und Martin Kindt dann den Simbo aus Havelsa aus dem Hut zauberte, um vor der Presse nicht doof dazustehen, dass wir gar keinen jetzt haben. Das war auch so eine mittelgute Entwicklung für uns. Und seitdem schwirrt Baumgart so in den Köpfen der Lokalpresse und arbeitet sich in regelmäßigen Kommentaren ab, wie man sich jetzt mit dem HSV vergleicht, wie man Baumgart noch übertäubelt, um auf den Relegationsplatz zu kommen. Das ist sehr spannend, was glaube ich auch eine sehr einseitige Geschichte ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass das in der Fanszene sonst irgendjemanden interessiert. Ich finde es spannend, dass auch er das anscheinend in Hamburg nicht in den Griff kriegt. Aber wie gesagt, die Saison ist noch lang und wir haben über die Unberechnbarkeit der 2. Liga gesprochen. Ich glaube, der HSV ist so oft schon dran vorbei geschrammt. Ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern, wann die letzte große Aufholjagd des HSV war, wo sie quasi schon abgeschrieben waren auf Platz 6. War das letztes Jahr oder vorletztes? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Vorletztes, und dann doch noch in die Relegation sich hochgearbeitet. Also aufgeben werden die sich nicht. Und wie gesagt, je nachdem, was da zwischen Platz 3 und 7 aktuell noch so rumspielt, sind das noch neun Münzwürfe? Zehn? Neun? Wie viele haben wir noch?
Neun. Ja, das ist natürlich krass. Also von Platz 7 bis Platz 3 sind es drei Punkte Unterschied. 38 und ein Viert, Paderborn 39, Hannover 39, Düsseldorf 40, HSV 41. Und dann kommt schon die Lücke zu Heustern, Kiel mit 46 und natürlich zu St. Pauli mit 51, die jetzt zehn Punkte Vorsprung auf den HSV haben. Das geht natürlich auch runter wie Öl. Aber da haben wir eben, Pajk, Toucheon, die fünf Punkte Abstand zu Heustern, Kiel. Was läuft denn in Kiel besser? Dass man sich nicht in diese Phasen reinziehen lässt. Die anderen Vereine hatten so eine richtig schlechte Phase. Das hattet ihr ja eigentlich nie in dieser Saison.
Ja, mit Pech kommt sie noch. Also wir hatten irgendwie immer das Glück, dass wenn wir gerade so auf dem Weg waren, in eine schlechte Phase reinzurutschen, haben wir es dann doch irgendwie geschafft, da rauszukommen. Also der Rückrundenstart war ja auch nicht gut mit einem 2-1 Niederlage gegen Braunschweig, 2-1 Niederlage gegen Fürth, ein Unentschieden in Magdeburg, wo wir eigentlich hätten auch gewinnen müssen, aber Fußballspielen eingestellt haben. Und dann kam Schalke zum Glück noch zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo sie noch nicht so viel auf die Reihe bekommen haben. Und dann ja wirklich ein überragendes Spiel gegen Paderborn und ein sehr, sehr spannendes Spiel gegen St. Pauli, sag ich mal. Also wir haben es dann irgendwie immer geschafft, so kurz bevor man dachte, so, oh, das war's, jetzt kommt so eine kleine Negativserie, haben uns da irgendwie wieder rausmanövriert. Ja, und in der Rückrunde hatten wir dann noch dieses Verletzungspech, also Pichler, unser Top-Stürmer, sag ich mal, fällt aus, die ganze Zeit fiet er ab, gerade als er endlich mal nach zwei, drei Jahren richtig mal wieder in Fahrt kam, mit fünf Treffern in Folge, glaube ich sogar, verletzt sich auch. Und dann musste jemand wie Joshua Mace, der eigentlich schon weg sollte, kam dann wieder in die Startelf und hat das eigentlich auch ganz gut gemacht. Ein Maschino, der so einen Formtief hatte, konnte sich so ein bisschen aus diesem Formtief rausspielen, auch wenn er jetzt nicht viele Tore gemacht hat, aber war doch wichtig fürs Spiel. Und ja, das war, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das Glück, was wir hatten, dass diese Leute, die von der Bank kamen, dann auch direkt funktioniert haben. Also auch Nijhoff von der U23 macht irgendwie sein Debüt und trifft direkt in Paderborn. Also da hatten wir dann irgendwie so das Fünktchen Glück, was anderen Vereinen vielleicht fehlte, dass wir diese doch großen Verletzungen, auch Sander, unser Kapitän am Anfang der Rückrunde, dass wir das irgendwie kompensiert bekommen haben.
Ja gut, entweder Glück kann natürlich sein oder halt ein Spielsystem, in die dann so junge Spieler oder eben auch Spieler, die auf der Ersatzbank saßen, gut reinrutschen können oder vielleicht auch ein Trainer, der es schafft, dann eine Umgebung zu schaffen, indem man das ganz gut umsetzen kann. Was glaubst du, was ist zum Beispiel der Anteil von Marcel Rapp am Erfolg?
Diese Saison auf jeden Fall groß. Letzte Saison stand er ja echt noch in der Kritik mit dem alten Kader, den er ja aber auch so halbwegs vorgefertigt übernommen hat. Und da kam das alles nicht so richtig ins Rollen, sein System. Und dann ja zu der neuen Saison waren ja glaube ich knapp 16 Abgänge mit Stammspielern wie Hauke Wahl, Reese, Finn Bartels. Also auch wirklich Qualität, die uns verlassen hat. Wo man dann auch dachte, wenn da die Kaderplanung schiefgeht, kann man auch mal in den Abstiegskampf rutschen. Und ja, Rab hat es dann geschafft mit vielen jungen Spielern, auch vielen unbekannten jungen Spielern, es geschafft sein System dann so ein bisschen in deren Köpfe zu kriegen. Und auch, dass wir uns sehr, sehr gut auf den Gegner einstellen, sehr variabel sind. Also von Viererkette, Dreierkette, Fünferkette, da ist irgendwie alles dabei. Dann haben wir auch das Glück, dass ein Luis Holpi wirklich nochmal aufblüht. Am Anfang der Saison saß er auf der Bank sogar die ersten vier Spiele. Aber dann hat er so ein bisschen das Ruder an sich gerissen und ist jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr wegzudenken. Und ja, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das Zusammenspiel auch Holpi allgemein so ein bisschen der rechte Arm von Rab auf dem Platz. Also so gefühlt noch ein spielender Co-Trainer bei uns. Und ja, das ist dann so ein Zusammenspiel aus ganz vielen Dingen. Also man merkt, dass Holpi auch extrem Bock hat und mit seiner Erfahrung so vorangeht. Viele junge Leute anleitet und auch, dass die Leute, die wirklich selten eine Chance haben, wie jetzt Fried Jonsson oder auch Mees, der gefühlt die ganze Zeit nicht spielen durfte, dass die keine schlechte Stimmung verbreiten. Das ist, glaube ich, auch wichtig gewesen. Also die wissen einfach, was ihre Rolle ist. Auch jetzt haben wir im Winter einen Kirches-Kur zurückgeholt aus Polen, dessen Vertrag nicht verlängert wurde. Er dann irgendwann in Polen den Wunsch geäußert hat, gerne wieder zurück nach Deutschland bzw. Dänemark zu kommen. Und dann hat das irgendwie geklappt. Und auch er weiß so, ey, wahrscheinlich, vielleicht spiele ich auch gar nicht. Er hatte jetzt einen Einsatz, aber er hat auch schon für unsere U23 gekickt. Auch das war einfach so ein Transfer, wo man weiß, der ist für die Breite. Wenn er spielen muss, ist er da. Wenn nicht, sind auch alle Feinde damit. Und ich glaube, das sind aktuell so ein paar kleine Punkte, die dafür sorgen, dass alle Rädchen ineinandergreifen.
Und das heißt, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel Fabian Reisel bei Hertha BSC siehst oder eben Hauke Wal bei St. Pauli, da kriegst du keine Probleme mit der Galle oder so?
Nee, Fabian Reisel ist eh ein verdienter Spieler in Kiel, auch wenn ein paar meinen, in Berlin ihn auspfeifen zu müssen, was ich nicht so ganz verstehen konnte. Aber dem gönne ich nur das Beste. Er ist ein Top-Spieler. Ich finde es beeindruckend, wie schnell er in Berlin da Fuß gefasst hat und im Endeffekt sogar gefühlt komplett das gesamte Spiel auf ihn basiert. Also ohne ihn wird es deutlich schlechter aussehen. Und Hauke Wal, ich sage mal, der hat leider so seinen guten Ruf in Kiel mit den letzten ein, zwei Spielen kaputt gemacht und mit einigen Aktionen, die nicht so glücklich waren, sage ich mal.
Also in Spielen gegen Kiel dann?
Ne, ne, noch als er in Kiel war mit Sachen Verabschiedung und was weiß ich. Und ich sage mal, seine letzte Aktion war ein Eigentor gegen St. Pauli. Sich dann in der Nachspielzeit noch eine gelbe Karte aus dem Nichts abgeholt, damit er das letzte Spiel nicht spielen muss. Und als die Fans ihn feiern wollten auf dem Zaun, ist er nicht mehr in die Fankurve gekommen. Und viele so Kleinigkeiten, wo man denkt, na, das muss einfach nicht sein. Aber gut, ey, der spielt jetzt wieder echt einen guten Ball in St. Pauli. Und also, ja, wir konnten es gut verkraften. Und ich sage mal, würden wir jetzt auf dem 13. Platz stehen, würde ich vielleicht anders reden. Aber vermissen tun wir sie aktuell nicht, nee.
Das ist schon einigermaßen absurd. Also Jan, du hast schon sehr breit gegrinst, aber ich muss auch deine Fabian-Rese-Meinung da natürlich noch abholen. Das ist ja wirklich bizarr, dass ein Team einen solchen Spieler abgibt, der eine so große Rolle spielt bei einem Absteiger und dann ist das eine Team auf dem Tabellenplatz 2, das ist Kiel, und das andere ist auf Tabellenplatz 11, das ist die Hertha. Wir kommen natürlich noch auf die Details, wie es jetzt dahinkam und so weiter und so fort. Aber wie denkst du über diesen Resetransfer? Er war ja fast schon existenziell für die Hertha jetzt in der Rückschau.
Das war zuerst mal der einzig gute Transfers, den Fredi Woobic gemacht hat in der Zeit hier bei Hertha, war, der jetzt irgendwie noch überlebt hat. Ja, es ist ein bisschen erschreckend, wie sehr Hertha vor ihm abhängt. Und ich wundere mich immer, wie man, wenn er dann zugestellt ist, nicht daraus irgendwie einen Vorteil ziehen kann. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass er seit der Vertagsverlängerung vor dem Kiel-Spiel war, das glaube ich, nicht mehr so die Leistung bringt und auch ein bisschen eher öfter schnell schießt. Es gab am Anfang des Kiel-Spiels so ein paar Szenen, da hat er sofort draufgehalten, das war alles ein bisschen seltsam. Aber Peik hat recht, er ist ein toller Typ, wahrscheinlich fein auch noch ein bisschen wegen der ganzen anderen Sachen, die er nebenher macht, aber harter Kämpfer. Oder wie Paldat er sagte, elf Fräse und ich gewinne jedes Spiel.
Ja gut, er hätte gerne tausend Fräse, das ist ein super, super Spieler. Ja, kann man gut verstehen, ihr hattet ja gerade das Aufeinandertreffen, also in Berlin, 2-2 war es am Ende. Peik, hat man da dann auch eine Entwicklung im Team gesehen, dass man eben mit einer Mannschaft wie Hertha so mithalten kann? Oder ist auch das eigentlich so konstant gut in dieser Saison? Und dann gibt es natürlich auch mal Niederlagen, jeder von dir. Genau.
Also eigentlich, im Durchschnitt muss man sagen, hat Kiel immer gezeigt, dass sie diese Saison mit jedem Team mithalten können. Sei es jetzt zu Hause ein überzeugender Heimsieg gegen den HSV. Gut, das ist für Kiel keine Saison. Nichts Schwieriges, aber trotzdem. Und auch das Hinspiel gegen Hertha war ja jetzt keine klare Niederlage. Das war ja auch kurz vorm Schluss durch 2. Elfmeter entschieden. Gegen Schalke, erstes Hinspiel überzeugend 2-0 gewonnen. Also dann zuletzt gegen Paderborn, die wirklich zu Hause quasi an die Wand gespielt. Ja, also man hat eigentlich gesehen, so typisch 2. Liga, wenn es gut läuft, können wir es wirklich mit jedem aufnehmen. Und auch gegen Hertha, das war ja gerade das erste Tor, war ja wirklich ein eklatanter Fehler. Das war ja fast ein vielen Eigentor. Wenn das nicht fällt und wir nicht mit Rückstand in die Halbzeit gehen, wer weiß, wie es dann ausgegangen wäre. Man ist ja auch bezeichnet, wenn Hertha gefühlt bei einem Heimspielen nichts macht, außer auf Konterspielen. Wir hatten glaube ich zur Halbzeit fast 70 Prozent Ballbesitz oder 65 Prozent Ballbesitz. War natürlich eine gute Taktik von Hertha, die ist voll aufgegangen. Lass Kiel machen, lass sie in Fehler laufen und die nutzen wir aus. Gerade mit einem gefährlichen Konterspieler, wie Reza ja auch ist. Aber ich würde sagen, verstecken muss man sich wirklich auch spielerisch vor keinem Verein in der 2. Liga aktuell.
Also 2-0-Führung war das zur Halbzeit, dann 81. Minute 1 zu 2 und 98. Minute 2 zu 2. Das ist ja die alte Weisheit, der Schiedsrichter pfeift erst ab, wenn Kiel ausgeglichen hat. Wer weiß es nicht. Jan, würdest du bei der Einschätzung zu diesem Spiel, würdest du da mitgehen?
Ja, also Ballbesitz Hertha geht gerade leider gar nicht. Es gab ab und zu mal, wobei Kiel noch so ein Spieler war, wo es ein bisschen gut lief, aber es ist auch nicht das, was sie können. Und gerade so Mannschaften wie Kiel, Pauli, Lange zusammen, da ist bei Hertha, ist ja alles einmal durchgewürfelt worden vor langer Zeit. Aber ich glaube im Hinspiel war es doch genauso, war dann nicht auch ein 2-0 zur Halbzeit und dann hat Kiel schnell ausgeglichen.
Kann gut sein. Ich erinnere mich da wirklich nur noch an diese Endphase, wo wir irgendwie 11 Meter dann gehalten, dann wieder 11 Meter und dann leider verloren, ja.
Genau, aber Jan hat völlig recht, es war genauso zur Halbzeit, stand es 2-0 und dann Ausgleich, aber diesmal bis zur 57. Minute und dann kamen hinten raus diese 11 Meter und diesmal dann eben für Hertha das 2-3. Aber Pike, sag mir noch ein paar Takte zu den Wechseln, weil du hast es schon angesprochen, ihr hattet 16 Abgänge und wir wissen ja jetzt, hat wunderbar funktioniert, mit den paar Neuzugängen und ein paar jungen Spielern das aufzufangen und trotzdem muss es ja irgendwie bitter sein, dass du eben Spieler wie eben die angesprochenen Wal und Reese, aber ja auch noch andere abgibst und dafür in aller Regel gar keine Ablöse kassierst. Ist das schlechtes Kadermanagement oder sehr gutes Kadermanagement, weil man im Falle, dass man mal den sportlichen Erfolg nicht hat, eben auch nicht auf irgendwelchen Verträgen sitzen bleibt?
Ja, also die paar Male, wo uns ja wirklich auch Leistungsträger verlassen haben, ablösefrei, ich sag jetzt mal ein Lii zum Beispiel, was ja wirklich auch weh tat, das waren oft dann auch Saisons, wo wir schon noch oben mit dabei waren und unser Sportdirektor dann eher gesagt hat, bevor wir jetzt irgendwie, wir können jetzt kurz vor Vertragsende vielleicht noch 500.000 für ein Lii bekommen, wenn er uns aber zum Aufstieg schießt oder ein Serra damals, dann sind es halt ein bisschen mehr als 500.000 und da wurde dann einfach darauf gesetzt. Letzte Saison, da wurde glaube ich einfach auch gemerkt, so wie man auch gehört hat so intern, dass einfach von der Stimmung einfach so ein bisschen war, ey wir müssen jetzt mal aufräumen irgendwie, dass so wie es jetzt ist, funktioniert es nicht. Wir müssen quasi so einmal durchwischen und ja, dass es dann nicht für jeden Geld gibt, klar ist ärgerlich, ist aber glaube ich für einen Verein wie Kiel auch nicht immer unvermeidbar und so war es dann glaube ich ein guter Cut, wo man sagt, so eh fast alle Verträge laufen auskommen und wir hätten Reze ja auch verkaufen können, schon im Winter, aber ja, da wollten die dann doch eher den maximalen sportlichen Erfolg rausholen und ja, ich glaube, das ist immer so ein bisschen das Ding gewesen von Kiel. Die einzig größeren Ablösen bisher waren ja glaube ich Kind Zombie damals, der HSV hat glaube ich 3 Millionen bezahlt und auch Drexler damals nach Mütcheland, aber ansonsten ja, ist ein bisschen ärgerlich, aber jetzt zum Beispiel Sander hat seinen Vertrag auch vor der Saison verlängert, aber halt mit einer Klausel, die jetzt gezogen wurde, dann ist das glaube ich schon okay und das Gute ist, dass wir auch nicht so extrem aufs Geld angewiesen sind. Wir sind jetzt nicht reich, aber wir wirtschaften auch so, dass wir ja nicht mit Minus aus Saison gehen.
Wer ist dafür verantwortlich? Ist es dann Schneeklod, der lange Zeit wichtige Rolle gespielt hat oder woher kommt das, dass Kiel so solide dasteht? Ihr seid ja auch sehr gut durch die Pandemie gekommen.
Genau, also Schneeklod, aber vor allen Dingen auch Schwenke, sehr so viele Dinge so hervorgeholt hat, so ein Störche-Club, wo so ein Zusammentreff mit sehr vielen Sponsoren, mit sehr vielen lokalen Firmen. Aber im Endeffekt ist das so ein Zusammenspiel aus allen, also die arbeiten ja auch alle mit dem Sportdirektor zusammen, der ist ja auch immer direkt quasi mit Vizepräsident, wird jetzt auch Sportdirektor und Vizepräsident wählen. Also das ist so ein kompletter Zusammenspiel aus allem irgendwie plus das Thema zum Beispiel jetzt das Stadionbau, was uns ja auch gefühlt schon seit 15 Jahren verfolgt. Da war es jetzt auch nicht so, dass Kiel sagt, ey komm, wir verschulden uns jetzt mit 70 Millionen und bauen uns irgendwie einen geilen Kasten hin. Wenn wir dann aber nach fünf Jahren wieder in der dritten Liga sind, wird uns das irgendwie den Boden unter den Füßen wegreißen. Sondern da wird schon ewig verhandelt mit der Stadt, dass da irgendwie ein guter Deal bei rumkommt. Und ja, das war auch bei Kiel schon immer so. Es war auch damals immer erstmal NLZ ausbauen. Da hieß es damals immer noch immer lieber Steine statt Beine. Also statt dass man irgendwie groß Ablöse für Spieler zahlt, versucht man selber welche aus dem NLZ hoch zu holen. Unsere U19, U17 schneidet ja eigentlich auch immer ganz gut ab. Also ja, ist wie gesagt so ein komplettes Zusammenspiel im gesamten Verein, die das irgendwie bisher gut durch die Jahre gebracht haben.
Also diese norddeutsche Euphorie, die macht mich völlig irre. Du bist ja kaum noch am Boden zu halten. Bei negativen Themen sagst du ja, ist so. Und bei positiven, ja, ist so. Aber gut, vielleicht kann Jan dich ja anzünden, der wollte noch was ergänzen.
Ich wollte nur fragen, in was für einer Größenordnung in das Stadion geplant ist bei euch?
Aktuell schwirrt die Zahl 25.000 Leute, also Plätze rum. Halt ich eigentlich auch für angemessen. Zuletzt war regelmäßig ausverkauft, aktuell sind wir immer so bei 15.000. Kommt natürlich auch immer drauf an, welcher Verein so bei uns spielt. Aber ich glaube, dass wir dann auch einen höheren Zuschauerschnitt bekommen würden, wenn da endlich mal ein ordentliches Stadion stehen würde und nicht so ein steilroher Gerüst.
Und dann hast du ja schon Carsten Wehmann angesprochen. Der kommt ja von Darmstadt 98. Alle diejenigen, die nicht den letzten Darmstads-Schwerpunkt im FIED Rasenfunk – Bundesliga Männer gehört haben, da haben wir darüber gesprochen. Das war nämlich durchaus überraschend und kann auch vielleicht als so kleine Niederlage von Darmstadt angesehen werden, denn Wehmann ist damit verantwortlich für viele, viele gute Transfers, die man gemacht hat. Das wurde jetzt so dargestellt wie ein Coup, dass man den geholt hat und gleichzeitig ein bisschen wie eine Rückkehr auf eine Art und Weise. Also ist das jetzt nur positiv zu betrachten, dass man mit Wehmann den Kaderplaner von Darmstadt holen konnte?
Also viel Negatives würde ich jetzt erstmal nicht darin sehen. Er war ja wirklich lange Zeit schon bei Holstein, damals Torwarttrainer, dann Chef-Scout, ziemlich lange. Und als er dann nach Darmstadt gewechselt ist, waren auch viele, die gesagt haben so, ey, warum ist er nicht sportdirekt bei uns geworden so? Das hätte sich eigentlich angeboten, wenn er schon so einen Job machen möchte. Und dann hat er in Darmstadt wirklich sehr, sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Stöver hat jetzt bei uns gesagt, er möchte aufhören. Da gibt es jetzt aber bisher jetzt noch nichts Offizielles, ob er danach irgendwas anderes macht oder weswegen. Aber was gut ist, dass er halt wirklich rechtzeitig Bescheid gesagt hat, dass jetzt auch schon beide da sind und bei uns arbeiten. Also die arbeiten jetzt noch gemeinsam die letzte Zeit und es ist nicht so, dass er ja in zwei Wochen musste mal irgendwie anfangen, unseren Kader zu planen. Und deswegen, also so auf dem Papier ist es erst mal was total Positives. Wie sie es dann entwickelt und wie seine Arbeit ist, muss man dann natürlich immer, oder kann man natürlich auch dann erst bewerten. Aber so sind wir erst mal, ja jetzt nicht euphorisiert, das gehört sich nicht mit deutschen Fingern.
Das hätte ich also nicht abgenommen.
Aber doch, mit dem Personal können wir sehr gut leben, ja.
Kann man mal machen, also das ist quasi bestmögliches Kompliment dafür. Ja, ich meine also zum einen ist natürlich interessant, also diese Karriere ist ja super vom Torwart-Trainer über Chef-Scout bis hin zum Sportdirektor ein sehr interessanter Weg und dann ja auch, dass er sich mutmaßlich, das unterstelle ich jetzt einfach nur, auch schon recht früh festgelegt hat, weil in Darmstadt war die Sache, das kam ja irgendwie so am 28. Dezember, kam raus, dass er fristgerecht zum 1. März gekündigt hat, also eben mit seiner Kündigungsfrist, die er hatte und dann hat der Darmstadt gesagt, ey sorry wir haben jetzt hier ein Winter-Transfer-Phasen-Fenster, dann trennen wir uns gleich einvernehmlich in Anführungszeichen. Aber das spricht ja schon so, dass er dann auch definitiv die Planung der neuen Saison rechtzeitig hätte angehen können. Und das ist ja wirklich untypisch für Sportdirektoren, die ja oft sehr, sehr spät reinkommen und im Grunde so eine Transferphase oft zur Hälfte schon mal vorbei ist, bis der Sportdirektor überhaupt anfängt. Das finde ich jetzt so im Nachhinein, wenn man eben weiß, okay, der hatte ja sehr wahrscheinlich einen Plan und so weiter und sofort. Das scheint mir alles recht stringent und logisch zu sein.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also als das dann so rauskam, hat man sich schon Hoffnung gemacht, dass Holstein Kiel die Adresse wird. Es hätte natürlich auch sehr gut Werder Bremen sein können, denn auch er kennt natürlich Ole Werner. Das hätte irgendwie auch gepasst, wenn die dann da zusammenarbeiten. Deswegen bin ich auch fast davon ausgegangen, dass es Werder Bremen wird, weil Holstein Kiel jetzt nicht direkt ein Rückschritt ist zu einem Verein wie Darmstadt, aber Werder Bremen ist natürlich dann doch mal eine andere Adresse. Aber dass es dann jetzt so gekommen ist und er wieder da ist, doch das freut uns. Weil auch als Chefscout hat er bei uns wirklich sehr, sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Sonst würden wir auch nicht da stehen, wo wir jetzt stehen. Und ja, wir freuen uns drauf.
Aber wirklich interessant, weil du sagst, es ist kein Rückschritt, auch finanziell nicht. Also Kiel hatte in den letzten gemeldeten Zahlen, das müsste ein 21, 22 sein, 30 Millionen Euro Rohergebnis. Darmstadt hat 26, 5 Millionen Euro Rohergebnis und der Personalaufwand ungefähr gleich. Also beide sind irgendwie so 15, 16, 17 Millionen Euro. Das ist schon wirklich interessant und zeigt ja vor allem, Pike, wo man hinkommen kann mit diesen Mitteln. Und jetzt sehe ich, dass ihr ja aktuell mit euren 46 Punkten schon so viele habt wie in der Vorsaison und einen mehr als in der vorletzten Saison. Das heißt, jetzt schon die beste Saison. Wo wird es hinführen? Glaubst du wirklich dran, dass es nach oben gehen kann?
Es ist wirklich, wirklich schwierig, weil auch in der Saison vor zwei Jahren oder drei Jahren, wo wir so noch zwei, drei Matchbälle am Ende hatten und nur noch ein Spiel hätten gewinnen müssen, denn wenn wir hochgegangen stattführt. Als Kieler, wie gesagt, ist man viel, viel leid gewohnt, auch durch jahrelang Regionalliga, Abstieg in die Oberliga. Wenn man so was alles mitmacht, dann ist ein Aufstieg in die Bundesliga auch als erster schleswig-holsteinischer Verein trotzdem noch so weit weg irgendwie oder beziehungsweise nicht wirklich vorstellbar im Kopf so. Es ist noch nicht realisierbar von den Gedanken. Aber ich sage mal, die Ausgangslage ist natürlich top mit fünf Punkten Vorsprung, neun Spiele noch zu gehen. Es kommen natürlich noch so diese unangenehmen Gegner. Wiesbaden kommt noch, jetzt Elbersberg, wir müssen auch noch mal gegen Osnabrück. Das sind alles Vereine, wo auch Kiel gerne stolpert, wie jeder Verein, der da oben so steht. Deswegen sehe ich das wie unser Trainer und wie eigentlich jeder Trainer der 2. Liga. Man muss von Spiel zu Spiel gucken und dann kann man gucken. Aber klar, freuen würden wir uns auch, auch wenn ich so ein bisschen Angst habe, wie das Stadion technisch aussieht, weil wir irgendwie gefühlt jetzt seit, seit wir in der 2. Liga sind mit Ausnahmegenehmigung spielen. Man schätzt schon bei den Fans so, dass unsere Heimspiele dann in Wolfsburg ausgetragen werden, weil kein anderer Nordverein sich das auch antun würde. Ja, also mal schauen. Aber klar, die Chance ist so groß wie noch nie, glaube ich, und die müssen wir versuchen zu nutzen.
Ja, also ich meine, du windest dich jetzt natürlich hier raus aus dieser Frage, musst du auch wahrscheinlich machen. Aber jetzt, Entschuldigung. Heimspiel gegen Hansel Rostock, gerade 16. Heimspiel gegen Osnabrück, gerade 18. Heimspiel gegen Kaiserslautern, gerade 15. Gut, Heimspiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf-Vierter, aber dann auswärts am 34. Spieltag in Hannover. Das ist ein sicherer Sieg. Ansgar, kannst du dir bestätigen?
Die letzte Saison hat es ja gezeigt.
Das Problem ist, dass wir zu Hause relativ schwach sind. Und auch in der Hinrunde, ne, Osnabrück irgendwie 1-1 und so. Also ja, mal schauen. Aber klar, also vom Papier, da kommen echt, also wenn man sich unser Restprogramm angeschaut und das Restprogramm der anderen Vereine, die da oben so stehen, ist alles dafür vorbereitet, dass wir da doch ein sehr, sehr gutes Ende draus nehmen. Aber als Fußballfan kann man das erst glauben, wenn es so weit ist.
Und ich habe natürlich völlig missachtet, dass ihr zwar in der Auswärtstabelle auf Platz 1 liegt, aber in der Heimtabelle eben nur auf Rang 7. Das hätte ich natürlich vorher nochmal gegenchecken müssen, bevor ich hier die… Aber ey, ich kann mich auf jeden Halb-Train setzen und den auch losfahren. Ich bin nicht emotional betroffen. Also, die Chancen sind auf jeden Fall groß. Und dann wollen wir jetzt mal besprechen, wie groß die Chancen denn für Hannover 96 sind. Da kann ich schon mal den kleinen Spoiler zulassen. Also, auswärts wird man wahrscheinlich nicht aussteigen. Da ist es nämlich genau umgedreht. Auswärts, Hannover, eigentlich schon traditionell, muss man fast schon sagen. Rang 10, also da ist man nicht ganz so stabil. Zuhause ist man eine Macht, Ansgar. 25 Punkte und damit Rang 3 in der Heimtabelle aktuell. Wird das irgendwie reichen können in dieser Saison?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der Trainer selber war oder ob es irgendwo nur mal wieder im Umfeld kolportiert wurde. Aber es wurde die Rechnung aufgemacht, naja, wenn man immer zuhause gewinnt und auswärts einen Punkt holt, dann hat man im Schnitt in zwei Spielen zwei Punkte im Schnitt. Und das reicht dann irgendwie, um oben mit dabei zu sein. Und ich glaube, so spielen wir auch gerade.
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Das weiß ich nicht. Uns kommt auch durch die Spielweise, die sich natürlich auch im Laufe der Saison wieder geändert hat. Wir haben, glaube ich, sogar mal wieder versucht, mit der Viererkette anzufangen zu Beginn der Saison, haben dann relativ schnell gemerkt, dass es nicht geht. Dann haben wir auf Dreier- Fünferkette umgestellt, um dann im Winter wieder auf Viererkette umzustellen, was ja Leitels Lieblingssystem ist. Er hat auch jetzt in dieser Woche nochmal in der Presse betont, dass wenn man Rauten spielt, dass der Gegner immer die Mitte zu stellt. Deswegen werden Flanken sehr wichtig werden. Ich glaube, da hat er auch an dich gedacht, als er das Statement verfasst hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob du unsere Highlights gegen Osterbrück und gegen Wien gesehen hast, gerade gegen Wiesbaden.
Hätte ich sie gesehen, dann hätte mein Kleinhörn dafür gesorgt, dass diese Erinnerung sofort gelöscht wird.
Wir haben ja das Topspiel jetzt am Wochenende gegen Kaiserslautern. Da wird es viel auf dich zukommen. Wir stehen zu Hause tatsächlich gut, sind bis auf die Niederlage in Überzahl gegen den HSV noch ungeschlagen. Die muss man dann einfach mal rausziehen. Was auch damit zusammenhängt, dass wir gerne mal ein frühes Tor schießen, um das dann locker runterzuspielen. Es gab ja in der Hinrunde dieses 7-0 gegen Osnabrück, was auch durch eine frühe rote Karte begünstigt wurde. Dann haben die sich in den Rausch gespielt in der zweiten Halbzeit. Andererseits hat diese Mannschaft auch ziemlich krasse Comeback-Qualitäten. Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt schon fünfmal in der Saison von einem 0-2 zurückgekommen. Auch gegen Hertha, auch jetzt gegen Düsseldorf vor zwei Wochen. Und immer mit Kurz vor Schluss dann doch noch auf dem Ausgleich und vielleicht sogar noch Richtung Siegtreffer gehen. Also da fragt man sich einmal, wenn so dieses frühe Tor ausbleibt und dann man doch in den ersten Konter läuft, dass man sich fragt, naja, woran liegt das? Was ist das jetzt für ein Gesicht, was die Mannschaft zeigt? Aber irgendwie scheint der Trainer sie in der Halbzeit auch irgendwie so anzustacheln, dass in der zweiten Halbzeit dieser Schwung reinkommt. Gerade auch durch die Kader-Tiefe, die man hat für die Offensive, dass man einen Vogelsammer noch bringen kann, dass man einen Torchert noch bringen kann, wobei der jetzt aktuell nicht wirklich in Form ist. Aber gerade Vogelsammer besticht gerade sehr mit seiner Joker-Form, dass man eben diese Wucht vorne noch reinbringen kann, um müde tiefstehende Mannschaften nicht herzuspielen. Also es sieht teilweise auch wirklich nicht schön aus, was dann da passiert, auch wenn der Trainer betont, wir spielen dann auf Sieg. Aber ja, es war dann gegen Wiesbaden zum Ausgleich auch wieder eine Halbfeldflanke, die dann doch mal einen Kopf fand und nicht die anderen 80, die nur den Kopf vom Wiesbadener, ich weiß gar nicht wie er heißt, Vukosic, irgendwie so, der 2-Meter-Verteidiger. Es war nicht wirklich schön anzusehen, aber am Ende holen sich irgendwie die Punkte und reißen die Leute mit und deswegen stehen sie da, wo sie stehen. Wir sind auch immer noch rückrunden zweiter, obwohl wir die letzten drei Spiele nicht gewonnen haben, was jetzt auch wieder komplett für diese Liga spricht und von daher sind wir immer noch mit dabei. Ich glaube, ja eigentlich will man ja schon aufsteigen. Andererseits ist man wohl im Zeitplan, wäre es einem lieber, wenn man nächstes Jahr aufsteigen würde, gerade auch, was so die Kadergeschichte ausgeht. Ich kann es dir nicht sagen, aber es wird super defensiv geredet. Also ich sage mal so, als es in der Hinrunde einmal relativ gut lief und auch mal über Nacht auf Platz 3 lag, da kam ja Martin Kinten und hat gesagt, ach wieso nicht schon dieses Jahr. Das hat dazu geführt, dass die Mannschaft in der restlichen Hinrunde das Spielen eingestellt hat und wir dann irgendwie wieder abgerutscht sind. Und alle schon sagten, oh Gott, oh Gott, wenn das schon der gute Teil der Saison war, dann gute Nacht. Dann kam die Winterpause, wir stellen auf Viererkette um, verkaufen noch unseren einzigen richtigen Linksverteidiger in die Türkei und spielen jetzt Not gedrungen. Oder ist Not gedrungen, wir spielen jetzt mal mit Marcel Halzenberg auf Linksverteidiger und gucken mal, was passiert. Und dann irgendwie so haben sie sich so berappelt, dass man jetzt dann doch wieder die Siege hintereinander eingetütet hat. Auch dieses wilde Spiel gegen Hamburg, was man eigentlich schon wieder aus der Hand gegeben hatte, um es doch noch zu gewinnen. Also Nürnberg, das war wirklich eine grottige Leistung von Nürnberg an dem Freitagabend, als die bei uns waren. Rostock war halt ein knappes Ding, aber schon verdient. Fürth war auch wieder von dem 0-1 zurückgekommen. Düsseldorf vom 0-2 zurückgekommen. Das läppert sich irgendwie so zusammen und man spielt sich oben fest und man weiß auch, okay, man hat die Qualität, aber ganz nach oben traut sich anscheinend die Mannschaft selber noch nicht zu. Weil wir hatten das jetzt schon so oft, und das passiert einfach nicht.
Okay, ich meine, das kann man ja aus der Variante – verstehe ich das natürlich – alles andere wäre natürlich albern. Aussteigen ist immer besser als drin bleiben, selbst wenn man dann vor dem Plan liegt. Aber ich meine, jetzt ist hier ja so eine gewisse Ironie zu eigen, die du eigentlich immer so in dir hast. Und die habe ich jetzt auch so gegenüber Stefan Leitl rausgehört. Kann es sein, dass du nicht ganz so zufrieden damit bist, wie taktisch?
In welcher Hinsicht meinst du? Weiß ich gar nicht.
Na, weil du gesagt hast, 4er-Kette spielt er am liebsten, dann ist er zur 3er-Kette, jetzt ist er wieder bei seiner 4er-Kette und flankt die ganze Zeit. Ja, gut. Oder ist das wieder deine Form der Euphorie? Hab ich heute nur die Leute, die keine Euphorie, spürt ihr noch was? Könnt ihr mal bitte kurz pieksen, alle.
Du hast mich doch auch als Norddeutschen eingeladen. Du weißt doch, was du kriegst. Nein, es funktioniert ja. Ich sag mal, was ich wirklich an ihm bewundere, das habe ich auch letzte Saison schon gesagt, wie er den jungen Spielern vertraut. Bons aus der Akademie, die Hochgrund, ob es ein Trezoldi ist, der vorne Stamm spielt und auch gut spielt, ob es hinten ein Arrenbi ist, der Stamm ist und auch bleibt. Dann hast du einen Kader, einen Yannick Lührs, der gut genug ist, um reingeworfen zu werden. Du hast einen Enzo Leopold im Mittelfeld, der da spielt. Wir haben Udenne in der Sommerpause eigentlich perspektivisch für die 2. Mannschaft aus Alt-Gelinicke geholt. Der hat jetzt Profi-Debüt gegeben. Er ist sich, finde ich, wirklich gut, anders als viele andere Trainer, die wir vorher hatten und immer gesagt haben, wir wollen jetzt von Mert auf die Jugend setzen, die das aber nur gesagt haben, weil sie wirklich kein Geld hatten. Und er macht es halt wirklich und er vertraut den Leuten auch und schmeißt ihnen nicht zwei Spiele rein und danach haben sie nichts mehr bei uns zu melden. Das sorgt schon dafür, dass man da auch wirklich wieder mehr Verbundenheit mit der Mannschaft hat und das Gefüge, glaube ich, gerade ganz gut stimmt zwischen erfahrenen Spielern und jungen Spielern. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich jetzt so ironisch gegenüber Stefan Leitlin bin. Er ist manchmal erst sehr verbohrt in seinen Ansichten tatsächlich. Also wie gesagt, wenn er sagt, ich muss nicht unbedingt dieses Jahr aufsteigen, dann sage ich natürlich auch, naja, was soll das, mach doch einfach. Oder wie so immer, dieselben zwei, drei Wechsel. Aber unterm Strich läuft es unter ihm einfach stabil. Er ist halt so ein bisschen bei uns vor jetzt anderthalb, fast zwei Jahren präsentiert worden, so nach dem Motto, dass jetzt der Halsbringer, wir haben jetzt für einen Trainer mal eine halbe Million Ablöse bezahlt und der bringt uns jetzt nach oben. Genau. Nur halt irgendwie.
Aber immerhin ist er auch da.
Fünfzigmal kleiner, aber er ist auch da, genau. Und er wurde so ein bisschen näher und der hat Führt nach oben gebracht, wo dann auch gerne ausgeblendet wurde, unter welchen Umständen Führt damals dann tatsächlich auch hochgegangen ist. Ich sehe ihn als einen sehr soliden, guten Zweitligatrainer, das ist mehr als man verlangen kann. Gerade in unserer Historie, bei Hannover 96 oder auch wenn man sich andere Vereine in der 2. Liga anguckt, ich bin mit ihm sehr zufrieden. Ich sage, wenn wir nächstes Jahr aufsteigen, dann Respekt, dann würde ich nicht erwarten im Vergleich mit den Mannschaften, die sonst immer noch so rumspielen. Gut, ich habe jetzt auch erwartet, dass Hertha und Schalke eine andere Rolle spielen in dieser Saison. Und wer weiß, was nächstes Jahr von oben dann auch wieder runterkommt und versucht mitzuspielen. Gut, von Darmstadt jetzt vielleicht nicht, aber wenn Mainz runterkommt, wird, glaube ich, dann schon da ernst angearbeitet, direkt wieder aufzusteigen. Von daher, ich bin zufrieden mit ihm, mit dem, wie er arbeitet. Aber ich bin jetzt nicht, dass ich sage, das ist jetzt der Zweitliga-Pepp und der spielt alle in Grund und Boden. Wird er, glaube ich, selber von sich aber auch nicht sagen.
Ja, und jetzt hast du ja schon die jungen Spieler angesprochen und das haben wir auch das letzte Mal, als wir hier über Hannover gesprochen haben, schon mal so ein bisschen rausgearbeitet, dass es ja einfach eine ganze Reihe von 20- 21- 22-Jährigen gibt, die einfach, wie du eben sagst, in der Regel immer spielen und das in der Regel auch relativ auf einem konstant guten Niveau. Hat es denn auch dazu geführt, dass es eine andere Identifikation mit dem Team gibt im Umfeld?
Ja, generell ist die Akademie auch noch mal mehr in den Fokus gerückt. Das ist auch etwas, was sich Markus Mann aufs Tableau geschrieben hat, als er bei uns angefangen hat, und setzt das auch konsequent um. Ich meine, unsere zweite Mannschaft ist momentan, ich sage mal, sehr stark im Aufstiegskampf in die dritte Liga. Es liegt auch daran, dass genug Menschen oder Spieler mit Profivertrag da regelmäßig aushelfen. Und die Regionalliga Nord ist jetzt wirklich nicht die beste aller Regionalligen. Uns kommt natürlich auch noch zugute, dass die zweite Mannschaft von Kiel auf eine Lizenz verzichtet hat für die dritte Liga, dass sie sich quasi da ausgeklinkt haben. Ich glaube, unser ärgster Konkurrent aktuell ist Phoenix Lübeck, die dann auch hausieren gehen müssen. Ich glaube, die haben beim VfB Lübeck angefragt, ob sie da mal in die Lohmühle können vielleicht. Wobei die vierte Liga, die Regionalliga Nord, muss ja auch noch die Aufstiegsspiele gegen Bayern spielen. Die müssen ja vermutlich noch nach Würzburg fahren. Aber nichtsdestotrotz gibt es halt auch um diese U23 rum, den, ich sage mal, kleinen Hype innerhalb der Fanszene. Da mal zu sehen, dass man in der Akademie nicht nur viel Geld lässt, sondern dass da tatsächlich auch junge Spieler zurückkommen, die aus der U19, die aus der U23 es schaffen, in den Profikader zu kommen und auch nicht nur für zwei Spiele und dann kriegen sie den Profivertrag und haben ausgesorgt und versuchen sich vielleicht bald mal wieder in der dritten Liga 3 oder 4, sondern tatsächlich auch nachhaltig da zu sein. Das hat schon tatsächlich, sorgt für gute Stimmung rund um den Maschsee.
Hatte etwa jemand vor ein paar Jahren Steine statt Beine gesagt? Diesen Spruch, den ich vorhin bei Pike zum ersten Mal gehört habe. Das ist ja völlig verrückt. Junge Spieler ausbilden und dann teuer verkaufen. Das ist ja bahnbrechend.
Ja, wobei Thema, wenn es um Bauten im Vereinsumfeld geht, das ist ja bei uns auch so ein rotes Tuch mit Hinblick auf Finanzmittel des EV und der KGAA und Hannover Vertrag und so. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt genau das NLZ ist oder ob es generell um das neue Vereinszentrum vom EV geht, aber es gibt da entsprechende Geschichten, die wissendere Menschen als ich besser aufbereiten können. Aber du weißt ja, wir haben ja die Neverending Story, die ja weitergeht. Wir haben ja das nächste Kapitel aufgeschlagen.
Ja genau, und darüber müssen wir leider auch sprechen. Es ist ja absurd, dass es keinen einzigen Hannover 96 Schwerpunkt in den 10 Jahren Rasenfunk gab, in dem nicht irgendwann das Wort Martin Kindfiel und nicht irgendwie so – ja der ist ja auch noch da und der hat mal was Gutes gesagt und so und da haben alle gesagt – Mensch danke Martin für diesen Input – sondern es ist immer so, dass wir hier über EV, KGAA, über irgendwelche – ich hab schon wieder die drei Unternehmen – hast du das nicht auf der Homepage liegen, unser F1-Konstrukt? Ja eigentlich hatte ich das immer hier so an der Wand, aber ich dachte ich kann es jetzt runter machen und dann kam Martin Kindt und hat in Hart aber fair die ganze Liga angezündet und das ist ja tatsächlich so das Ding. Also Martin Kindt hat mutmaßlich anders abgestimmt, als der EV ihn gebeten hat abzustimmen und sehr wahrscheinlich zumindest hat man das in Kauf genommen von Seiten der DFL durch die verdeckte Abstimmung, dass das eben auch möglich sein würde, ohne dass es eben rauskommen würde und das ist ja einer der wesentlichen Kipppunkte gewesen des Investoren-Deals und das viel größere Thema ist aber und ich glaube das merken wir gerade, das werden wir auch merken im Nachklang der Sache, die gerade in Stuttgart passiert, das werden wir in der nächsten Woche im Rasenfunk hier nochmal ausführlicher thematisieren. Es gibt gerade einen 50 plus 1 Kipppunkt und ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe diese Hardtabber-Fair-Sendung mit Martin Kind gesehen und natürlich kann man sich da über ganz viele Dinge sehr lustig machen, die er da gesagt hat und dass er halt einfach in seiner ganzen Martin Kind-Artigkeit halt einfach da sitzt und so vor sich hin redet. Ich glaube aber, dass der an manchen Punkten Streichhölzer dabei hatte und Feuer gelegt hat. Ich glaube, der hat im Kartellamt mehrere Feuer angezündet mit Rauchsignal. Hier guckt mal, 50 plus 1 wird doch sowieso die ganze Zeit gar nicht eingehalten. Ist euch schon mal aufgefallen, dass die ganzen Finanzgesellschaften gar nicht weisungsgebunden sind? Die haben gar nicht so einen Hannover-Vertrag wie bei uns, der übrigens gar nicht gültig ist. Den lege ich ja komplett anders aus. Also kann es sein, dass Martin Kind vielleicht seinem Ziel, 50 plus 1 zum Kippen zu bringen, näher ist als jemals zuvor?
Vermutlich, weil ich sage mal, immer wenn er sich ins tagesaktuelle Fußballgeschäft versucht hat, einzumischen mit Transferwünschen oder Saisonzielen, dann ist das ja immer regelmäßig in die Hose gegangen. Aber was man ihm wirklich nicht abstreiten kann, ist, dass er von Wirtschaft und wie funktionieren Firmen tatsächlich sehr viel Ahnung hat und wie gehe ich strategisch vor, um Ziele zu erreichen. Ich meine, er hat nicht umsonst ein Firmenimperium, was seinen Namen trägt. Und auch wenn du den Hannover-Vertrag ansprichst, das ist ja, ich sage mal, wohlerübel. Über Jahre haben manche absichtlich so konstruiert worden, dass am Endeffekt der EV, als er nicht mehr die Macht im EV hatte, der finanziell so unter Zugzwang war, um in diesen Hannover-Vertrag einzuwilligen. Und natürlich legen beide Seiten den anders aus, aber alleine, dass der EV finanziell so im Zugzwang war, um zu sagen, wir nehmen diese paritätische Regelung. Klar, können sie immer noch sagen, wir gehen dann da raus, aber dann stehen sie halt komplett ohne Geld da als EV. Und da müssen sie erst mal neue Investoren irgendwie sich aus der Luft zaubern, die nicht Martinkins beste Freunde sind. Und das ist in Hannover und Umland dann schon ein bisschen dünn, gerade wenn man mit dem Versprechen angetreten ist, das mehr an die Basis zurückzuholen. Dann kann man jetzt auch nicht mit einem aller Welt-Sponsor aus sonst woher kommen, um zu versuchen, Martinkind abzulösen. Es sollte ja schon einen regionalen Bezug haben. Und ich glaube, genau so geht da auch das Thema 50 plus 1 an. Ich stimme mir auch zu. Die DFL hat sich ja oft genügend schlanken Fuß dabei gemacht, wenn es darum ging, wirklich mal klare Kante zu sagen, ob das jetzt 50 plus 1 so jetzt ist oder nicht. Im Nachklapp, als dann der Investoren-Deal scheiterte, gab es ja so ein bisschen Stichelei von Vatzkes Seite in seine Richtung. Da hat er dann wieder zurückgestichelt in Richtung BVB. Also natürlich, das wird noch eine ganz lustige Nummer werden in den nächsten Monaten. Dazu ist ja dieses ganze Martin-Kind-Aberufungsgeschichte, geht ja im Juni vom BGH weiter in Revision. Also wir haben Stoffe, Schlagzeilen für Jahre und immer mit Hinselben. Und gleichzeitig wird der gute Mann ja auch nicht jünger und seine Nachfolge ist nicht geregelt. Also wir können hier Jahre lang…
Sollte das nicht sein Sohn werden? Habt ihr das nicht mal irgendwann?
Ja natürlich, aber das muss ja auch durch dieses Gremium durch.
Na gut, das wird er schon so eingerichtet haben in sämtlichen Verträgen und so weiter, dass es da durchgeht.
Naja, außer der EV hat ja auch zwei Stimmen, das muss ja mehrheitlich. Es ist ja 2 zu 2.
Stimmt, das ist 2 zu 2 und dann, genau, das ist ja quasi der…
Ja, deswegen konnte ja auch die EV-Seite keinen neuen durchdrücken, weil es ja 2 zu 2. So, und genau da sind wir seit drei Jahren oder so.
Aber gibt es da einen Ermüdungseffekt? Also, weil wir haben zwar gesehen, es gab die Fadenkreuz-Banner übrigens nicht nur gegen Martin Kind, sondern auch gegen den Potter von CWC. Also, es ging nicht nur um Martin Kind.
Und Voldemort, das war das Fürth-Spiel.
Und Voldemort gab es noch, Angst-Potter. Also, das heißt, da haben wir quasi die üblichen Mechanismen gesehen und da kann man jetzt auch im Einzelfall darüber werten, wie man möchte. Aber die Frage ist für mich eine größere. Gibt es einen Ermüdungs- oder Gewöhnungseffekt an Martin Kind und an diese Situation? Kann es sein, dass hier vielleicht so mit der Geschwindigkeit der Kontinentalplattenverschiebung sich vielleicht auch die Mehrheitsmeinung dahin dreht, dass man sich denkt, bevor wir immer dieses ätzende Getue haben und diese Gerichtsverhandlungen und diese komischen Interviews, die ja auch keiner versteht? Ich meine, ich habe mich schon 15 Mal eingelesen in diese Hannover-Sache. Ich habe trotzdem das Gefühl, gerade nicht alles hier oben im Hirn zu haben. Kann es sein, dass sich vielleicht das Umfeld in Hannover 96, vielleicht exklusive der organisierten Szene, die sich klar positioniert, so langsam ein bisschen ändert in der Meinung und man sich denkt, naja gut, er hat ja so viel Gutes getan, der Martin.
Ja, also ich glaube, generell war es ja nie so, dass es immer eine Mehrheit gegen ihn gab. Es gab ja jahrelang auch auf den EV-Mitgliederversammlungen immer eine Mehrheit für ihn und seine Koalition. Das hat sich ja wirklich nur über diese organisierte Fernsehen überhaupt mal irgendwann entwickelt. Das ist auch nicht im EV diese, ich sag mal, diese immer genannte schweigende Mehrheit. Natürlich, der normale Stadiongänger, entweder befasst er sich nicht in dieser Tiefe damit oder sagt halt, naja, aber das ist halt Martin Kind und der hat uns aus der Regionalliga geholt und der war schon einmal weg und dann gab es Nachfolger und die haben das Ding in Rekordzeit gegen die Wand gefahren, dann musste er wiederkommen. Natürlich ist dieser Eindruck da und deswegen, viele werden sagen, ach jetzt, bleib doch mal ruhig, jetzt habt ihr jetzt den Kind gesungen, ja super, aber jetzt langt es auch so nach dem Motto und aber wie gesagt, es zeichnet sich ja nichts anderes ab. Bevor es sein Sohn werden sollte, wir hatten ja auch irgendwann mal die Idee, Robert Schäfer als potentiellen Nachfolger zu installieren, der hat uns ja den aktuellen Premium-Hauptsponsor organisiert, der im Sommer leider auslaufen wird, aber ja auch der ist dann irgendwie mal von Martin Kind geholt worden, sag mal du wirst jetzt hier Geschäftsführer und bald dann auch mein Nachfolger und dann hat der EV gesagt, aber da wissen wir gar nichts von, dann ist das auch wieder auf Eis und so manövriert sich und gleichzeitig agiert Martin Kind auch medial cleverer als der EV, auch juristisch cleverer als der EV, wie es jetzt mehrfach schon nachgewiesen wurde, sodass dann auch wenn die Leute wirklich nur die Zeitung aufschlagen und lesen, ok und der EV hat schon wieder juristisch gegen Martin Kind vor und sagt, naja was macht denn der EV dann da auch, dann lasst doch den Martin Kind, der weiß wenigstens, wie man irgendwas ohne Schlupflöcher ordentlich einfädelt oder zumindest für seine Das sind seine Schlupflöcher. Ja, aber das wird uns noch weiter begleiten, Max.
Es hört sich ehrlich gesagt wie eine unglaublich verfahrene Situation an, die auch ein bisschen einem die Lust nimmt, darüber zu sprechen. Da könnte jetzt nur ein Aufstieg mit einer krassen Euphoriewelle das Ganze durchbrechen.
Du weißt, ich kann genauso euphorisch wie Pike. Also erstmal haben wir am Samstagabend Kaiserslautern, die kommen mit 5000 Leuten zu uns. Dann fahren wir Ostern nach Magdeburg, auch schön. Dann kommt Schalke, dann gibt es das Derby in Braunschweig, dann Pauli, dann Hertha. Also wir haben noch quasi gegen alle, also ich glaube mal bis auf Hamburg und jetzt Düsseldorf, Hamburg glaube ich noch von alle da oben. Na gut, Fürth, aber Fürth, die machen ja nichts mehr. Aber wir haben im Grunde gegen alle da oben noch zu spielen. Sahen jetzt eigentlich nie gut aus, hinterher Runde, aber das muss ja nichts heißen. Ja natürlich, wenn es klappt, ich bin der Letzte, der sich wehrt. Gleichzeitig, wenn man auf die Historie schaut, Platz 3 heißt ja im Grunde, ihr steigt auch nicht auf. Und Platz 2 ist halt schon was weg. Aber das kann ein, also in anderen Saisons haben wir zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon längst aufgehört, um uns, um irgendwelche Platzionen Gedanken zu machen, weil Platz 16 war weg und Platz 3 war weg und zwar deutlich. Es ist immer schön, dass noch um was geht. Jetzt kommt auch wieder schönes Wetter. Zuhause gewinnen wir gerne mal. Außer am letzten Spieltag, wenn Kiel vorbei kommt, historisch gesehen. Aber es muss ja dieses Jahr nicht so sein.
Ja, okay, es ist so ein guter Punkt. Also dieses Restprogramm, das hat es wirklich in sich. Und wie gesagt, der dritte Platz reicht ja oft nicht. Es ist, ach, ich kann mich halt noch an die Zeiten erinnern, in denen wir halt in den Erstligasendungen über Hannover 96 gesprochen haben. Und das ist immer sehr ungerecht, denjenigen Vereinen gegenüber, die noch nie in der ersten Liga waren in den letzten zehn Jahren. Aber ich denke mir immer, Mensch, da habe ich doch schon so viele Gäste. Und mit denen könnte ich doch jede Woche sprechen. Jetzt steigt doch endlich mal wieder auf. Aber ja, ich sehe schon.
Wir arbeiten noch dran. 2025.
2025. Okay, ich nehme dich beim Wort. Und ich werde Stefan Leithlen persönlich fragen, warum der Ansgar mich belogen hat, wenn das nicht geklappt hat. Weil ihr es am letzten Spieltag zu Hause gegen Kiel vergeigt. Dann werde ich sagen.
Jetzt hast du jetzt gerade Pikes Aufstieg getingst.
Stimmt, dann habe ich gleich drüber nachgedacht. Ich sage gar nichts mehr voraus in der 2. Liga. Aber dieses Problem mit den Gästen, die man hat, mit der Auswahl an Gästen, und dass man sehr, sehr gut Sendung machen kann, das habe ich ja auch bei Hertha WSC. Aber da, lieber Jan, da will ich jetzt die Aufstiegsfrage gar nicht stellen. Aus guten Gründen. Hertha liegt auf Rang 11. 34 Punkte hat man, damit hat man 7 Punkte nach oben auf den HSV. Man hat 9 Punkte nach unten auf Hansa Rostock aktuell. Und ich würde die These in den Raum stellen, oder dir zum Fraß vorwerfen, dass die 9 Punkte nach unten gerade die beste Nachricht sind. Weil bei allem, was schon passiert ist bei Hertha in dieser Saison, gab es mehrmals die Chance, dass man richtig, richtig nach unten durchrauscht. Aber danach sieht es jetzt gerade nicht aus, oder?
Wir sind Rückrunden 16. Also kannst du draus machen, was du möchtest. Aber es sieht schon nicht so rosig aus, würde ich sagen. Unter dem Eindruck des Aushaltspiels bei St. Pauli.
Okay, also, ja, hast du natürlich recht. Also erst zwei Siege, drei Unentschieden jetzt in der Rückrunde. Und da sind ja auch schon acht Partien gespielt. Aber dass man ja trotzdem noch neun Punkte Vorsprung hat, zeigt ja, die da unten stellen sich ja halt mal wieder an. Und vor allem, weil eben so Teams wie Braunschweig und Rostock angefangen haben zu punkten, haben die sich auch gegenseitig Punkte weggenommen. Schalke ist seine, seine ganze Schalkehaftigkeit wieder ein einziges, ein einziges, es gibt doch bei den Simpsons diese Reifenmüllhalde, die einfach ganzjährig brennt. Und das ist ja Schalke 04 im Grunde. Also das heißt ja, Rückrunde natürlich nicht gut. Musst du mir auch gleich erklären, warum. Aber trotzdem ist man ja noch nicht so richtig da unten reingerückt. Ist das nicht, also vielleicht versuche ich auch gerade, dir nur positive Dinge hinzuwerfen, an denen du dich aufrichten kannst. Du sollst ja durch den Tag kommen. Aber man kann es doch auch positiv deuten.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das Team hat einfach im Dezember gepiekt. Und seitdem geht es irgendwie stetig ein bisschen weiter bergab.
Aber warum? Woran liegt das?
Du hast zum ersten Mal im Sommer 30 Transferbewegungen gehabt. Du hast keine richtige Mannschaft zusammen. Dann ist der wichtigste Spieler Reese im Dezember ausgefallen mit Corona. Er war längere Zeit nicht dabei. Da gab es dann wunderbare Spiele wie das 0-0 gegen Osnabrück, bevor die angefangen haben, gut zu. Spielen. Jetzt stellt man sich die Frage, ob es eine weitere Entwicklung unter Dada gibt. Als der Kader durcheinander war und man drei Spiele mit 0-5 Toren verloren hat, gab es eine bessere Entwicklung. Dann haben sich leider die Kreativspieler alle auf einmal verletzt. Duziak hat jetzt eine Halbzeit gespielt und seitdem nicht mehr. Wenn man den Anfang der Saison und den Anfang der Rückrunde guckt, ist das alles sehr ähnlich.
Ja, aber zum Anfang der Rückrunde immerhin einen Punkt aus den ersten drei Spielen geholt und nicht null Punkte aus den ersten drei Spielen. War es nicht so? Eine leichte Verbesserung. Aber das mit den vielen Transfers, das ist ja klar. Wir alle haben mitbekommen, wie dieser Umbruch bei Hertha war. Und dann Marco Richter noch weg und so weiter und so fort. Aber das kann ja nicht der Grund sein, dass man quasi zu viel Veränderungen hatte. Und jetzt im Winter fällt es ihnen auf. Oh, wir kennen uns ja alle gar nicht. Wir spielen jetzt auf einmal schlechter. Könnte es nicht vielleicht auch eher sein, dass man es ja dann doch geschafft hat, einen Fußball zu etablieren, der Erfolg hatte, mit dem man zumindest lange nicht verloren hat. Das war ja eigentlich so dann die Kernkompetenz von Hertha irgendwann. Es war nicht immer schön. Man hat auch nicht immer gewonnen, eher seltener sogar. Aber du hast halt nie verloren. Ist es vielleicht möglich, dass sich die Gegner besser darauf eingestellt haben? Weil ich habe jetzt nicht so viel von Hertha gesehen. Aber wenn ich Dinge von Hertha gesehen habe, dann war, wenn nicht gerade Fabian Reese am Ball war, war es ehrlich gesagt immer das Gleiche, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Ja, und es ist halt eben wirklich nur der Pass von hinten raus auf Fabian Reese, er geht auf den Flügel. Es gibt Ansätze in anderen Spielen, wo es dann wie gegen Magdeburg total super läuft. Er geht dabei vom Innenverteidiger gleich nach vorne, was man auch von Hertha gar nicht mehr so kennt. Irgendwie ein schönes Spiel. Aber jetzt, wo halt die Leute wissen, wir machen Reese zu, passiert nichts, ist bei Kiel so gewesen. Der hat nicht viel gemacht. Und jetzt auf St. Pauli war auch nichts zu sehen. Dann ist es halt alles ein bisschen, es ist ja immer noch Dadai-Ball. Dadai war erst nicht früher auch immer so, hinten gut stehen und vorne hilft der liebe Gott oder wieder die Bischewitsch jetzt in den letzten Jahren.
Ja, aber Dadai-Ball ist so lustig, dass wir jetzt in der 2. Liga immer vom Wall dabei, vom Dadai-Ball und so weiter sprechen. Aber wenn wir das mal so bezeichnen wollen, dann kennzeichnet dies ja auch. Also klar, defensive Stabilität, aber ja auch ein sehr, sehr hoher Laufaufwand. Eigentlich eine relativ gute Intensität in den Zweikämpfen. Und es ist eben einfach sehr unangenehm, gegen Hertha zu spielen. Wenn ich die jetzt aber so zuhöre und wenn ich mir auch die Ergebnisse angucke, eben in Braunschwalk 1 zu 1, dann eben das jetzt schon öfter zitierte 2 zu 2 gegen Kiel und jetzt zuletzt gegen St. Pauli. Gut, da haben schon andere verloren. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass das vor allem fehlt, dass es nicht mehr unangenehm ist, gegen Hertha zu spielen.
Das Problem bei St. Pauli ist ja nicht die Niederlage. Es ist ja, wie du verloren hast. Du hast in der ersten Halbzeit überhaupt keinen Stich, denn in der zweiten war es dann ein bisschen besser. Du warst niemals da dran, wirklich ein wirkliches Tor zu schießen, so etwas in die Richtung. Und Hertha ist ja auch irgendwie, erzählt ja jeder Reporter, der als allererstes, wenn es anfängt, ja, erster Halbzeit Meister. Und danach dann spiele man auch unentschieden oder verloren.
Also ein Konditionsproblem, jetzt haben wir es doch.
Nein, es ist kein Konter. Es ist einfach ein mentales Problem, weil er das, glaube ich, seit Jahren gibt. Auch so wie wir haben eine Chance, etwas Gutes zu machen. Halbfinale, Pokal 2016 gegen Dortmund, 0 zu 3 verloren und absolut nichts gebracht. Jetzt im Achtelfinale den HSV auf besondere Art und Weise das Spiel noch gewonnen und dann bist du gegen Lautern dran und auch so ein absoluter Rock-Krepierer. Vor allem so, wie Lautern jetzt die ganze Zeit spielt, ist ja nicht so, dass die jetzt dann noch irgendwie sich in den Aufstieg eingeschaltet haben. Man fragt sich jetzt, hat sich das Spielsystem entwickelt und ist er der Richtige, um die Mannschaft dann mit einer Weiterentwicklung nächstes Jahr zum Aufstieg zu bringen oder nicht? Und da ist man sich gerade nicht so sicher.
Nächstes Jahr steigt doch Hannover auf. Hey, ihr könnt jetzt nicht alle sagen, wir steigen nächstes Jahr auf. Ihr müsst euch da auch besser anwenden.
Es ist alternativlos, tut mir leid. Du hattest halt früher einen Rainer Wiedmeier als Co-Trainer, der immer nachgesagt wurde, er wäre der Taktikfuchs gewesen in dieser Verbindung. Und wie es jetzt mit Tamas Bodok läuft, da ist man sich nicht ganz so sicher. Und ich war eigentlich relativ okay, ist ja ganz nett. Also im Grunde, vielleicht so ein Jahr davor, ist es eigentlich traumhaft ruhig und nett. Aber nach oben wird es gerade nicht gehen. Und jetzt ist ein bisschen diese Katerstimmung da. Okay, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ja, gerade das, dieses Ruhige. Ich verfolge Hertha jetzt ja auch nur als Außenstehender. Aber für mich kommt es auch so darüber, als wenn gefühlt alle cool damit sind, dass Hertha im grauen Mittelfeld der 2. Liga diese Saison ist. Also klar ist irgendwie so die Abstiegssaison, aber trotzdem wird man ja irgendwie gerade auch so als Fan gedacht haben, gut, wir spielen zumindest irgendwie um den Aufstieg wieder mit. Aber nach außen, finde ich, wirkt es so, als wenn alle damit fein sind, dass Hertha so absolut gar keine Rolle in der 2. Und das erstaunt mich dann doch irgendwie.
Naja, also ich war auf der Milchdorfversammlung nach dem Abstieg aus der 1. Liga und das war eine der ruhigsten MVs, auf denen ich je gewesen bin. Da war ich dazu so, okay, also es gab MVs, da ist Hertha 10. geworden oder ganz knapp Europa verpasst mit Dada und danach war viel mehr Stress als auf diesen MVs. Und es ist wahrscheinlich dieser Demutsgedanke, den Kai Bernstein damit eingebracht hat und der leider nicht überall ankommt, aber der, glaube ich, ganz wichtig ist für Hertha in den nächsten Jahren.
Ja, aber da sind wir ja schon bei einem Thema, also wenn du sagst, es ist vor allem ein mentales Thema. Also es ist ja wirklich, ich meine, du kannst es jetzt nicht mehr hören, aber ich möchte es nochmal wiederholen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Nach der Tabelle der ersten Hälfte, da hat Hertha BSC mit 47 Punkten die meisten aller Zweitligesten, dass man Tabellenführer und dementsprechend schlecht ist es in der zweiten Hälfte und du hast schon gesagt, kein konditionelles Problem, sondern ein mentales Problem. Müssen wir dann auch den Tod von Karl Bernstein und alles, was dann quasi wie so ein Mühlstein auf der Rückrunde auf einmal lag, müssen wir das da mitbeachten?
Und ich habe jetzt immer mal überlegt, wie es gewesen wäre, wenn der vorherige Präsident einer Gegenbauer plötzlich verstorben wäre. Und ich glaube, das hätte kein Groß gejuckt, um es mal so ganz gemein zu sagen. Es war ein riesengroßes Ding, das immer noch auf einem hängt. Zumal ja auch zum ersten Mal nach Jahren der Misswirtschaft und der neuesten Pleiten Pech und Pannen und immer mehr Verlusten. Ich habe das vorhin nochmal nachgeguckt. Hertha hatte früher einen Aufwand von 62 Millionen beim Personal. Der ging dann auf einmal hoch auf 80. Da war Klingsmann. Dann kam Bobic. Dann war er bei 92 und bei 97. Du hast einen Verlustvortrag insgesamt von 447 Millionen, wenn ich alles zusammengerechnet habe. Dann wird 2026 und 2025 die 40-Millionen-Anleihe wieder fällig. Mit der haben sie nur die Lizenz bekommen, weil sie diese Anleihe um zwei Jahre verlängert haben. Die war eigentlich dieses Jahr fällig, aber das Geld war absolut nicht da. Der Verein hat sich schon sehr grundlegend verändert. Das höre ich von Leuten, die seit 20, 30 Jahren bei Hertha arbeiten. Es ist ein neuer Geist, und da ist dann alles auf einmal total zum Erliegen gekommen. Wenn Kai Bernstein jetzt noch leben würde, würde es mir um einiges besser gehen im Gesamtausblick auf die Zukunft von Hertha BSC.
Es ist jetzt reine Spekulation, aber das muss man doch fast auch auf dem Feld sehen, weil es ja quasi direkt auch unmittelbar vor Start der Rückrunde war. Ich habe mir das zum Beispiel bei diesem Ausschalten gegen Kaiserslautern gedacht, auf dem ja so ein unglaublicher Druck war, weil das das große Ziel ist von Hertha BSC. Und weil Pardada ja auch der Trainer ist, der das immer wieder und wieder gesagt hat, das ist mein Traum, ich will mal im Olympiastadion im Finale stehen. Und Kai Bernstein hat das auch sehr offensiv formuliert. Und es musste ja fast scheitern, weil das war quasi in dieser Situation vor einem ausverkauften Haus dann mit ja auch, keine Ahnung, 30.000 Lauterern oder so was. Das war ja quasi schon wie so ein Finale und das geht hat dann auch oft verloren. Weil man sowas noch nicht so oft durch erlebt hat. Also würdest du jetzt dann quasi sagen, wir können das mit reinnehmen und können sagen, diese sportliche Misere, die aber sehr wahrscheinlich hoffentlich nicht in einem Abstieg münden wird, weil dafür hat man eben noch genügend Polster, obwohl man jetzt wirklich eine schlechte Rückrunde spielt, dass es eben auch daher kommen kann, dass man eben so seinen einen ganz besonderen Moment hatte, der den ganzen Verein belastet.
Ja, es ist halt sehr diffus und ich weiß nicht genau, wiefern jetzt ein Eimann Barcock, der hier ankommt aus Mainz und dann zwei Tage vorher ist der Präsident gestorben, wie die Leute das betrifft. Aber er war schon nah dran, mehr dran als viele andere. Das ist aber auch jetzt, klingt alles immer ein Dade, der sagt, keiner ausreden. Zu dem Tod kam er noch hinzu, dass du an diese Krankheitswelle hattest, dass ganz viele Leute auch in diesem Spiel nicht spielen konnten. Dann war er der Reese, der überhaupt das Achtelfinale erst gewonnen hat. Quasi immer Leingang mit zwei Toren, einem Assist, dem entscheidenden Elfmeter. Und da hast du, glaube ich, du hast einfach alles Glück in diesem Spiel verbraucht. Und das kommt dann nicht mehr wieder. Abstieg sollte man nicht aus dem Auge lassen. Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass es passiert. Man muss jetzt nur nach vorne schauen, was man als nächstes macht. Also, dass Fabian Rees überhaupt verlängert hat, ist ja schon mal ein ganz großes Ding. Jetzt geistern gerade die neuen Sachen durch. Was ist mit den jungen Leuten? Und einer der Bänzer da, der der jüngste Sohn von Pall Dada, der soll bei Wolfsburg unterschrieben haben. Was mir ein bisschen mehr Sorgen macht, ist Berliner Weg. Wurde ja ausgerufen, wir machen was ganz Neues, wir arbeiten mit jungen Spielern. Und da hat die U23, die hat losgelegt wie die Feuerwehr, die haben noch nie so gut gespielt. Das Stadion war wirklich voll, sonst waren da, wenn es hochkommt, 200, 300 Leute, auf einmal war das wirklich knackeknacke voll. Und die sind da durchmarschiert. Und ich glaube, wir sind hier auf dem 15. Platz, haben das letzte Spiel. Da haben sie zwar gegen Greifswald gespielt, die Tabellenführer sind, haben aber auch mit vielen Profis es nicht geschafft, dieses Spiel zu gewinnen und haben dann 0-1 verloren. Und wie es in der Akademie weitergeht und was sich da entwickelt, ist ein bisschen auch eine Frage. Das ist nämlich das jetzt, was das einzige Fausthorn, was Hertha noch hat, ist, die Akademie. Und wenn jetzt da Leute weggehen, dann macht man sich ein bisschen Sorgen ums Ganze.
Gut, ich meine, da gab es ja auch schon ein bisschen Wechsel. Michael Hartmann zum Beispiel, langjähriger U19-Trainer, ist zu dem Bayern an Campus gewechselt. Und gleichzeitig gab es aber auch die größere Aufmerksamkeit. Ich habe gerade den Namen vergessen, welcher Spieler war der, der auch so viele Follower hat und quasi Influencer ist. Das hat natürlich auch dafür gesorgt, also ja mit fast schon chaotischen Zuständen inzwischen zeitlich, aber dass da eben erhöhter Fokus drauf war. Hertha ist gerade so in der Schwebe. Und die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, weil bei vielen Dingen, da wissen wir jetzt nicht, wie es sich weit entwickelt. Also kann man den Berliner Weg, den Kai Bernstein eingeschlagen ist? Wer sich dafür interessiert, habe ich ja in einem Tribüngespräch nochmal ausführlich versucht, nachzuzeichnen. Kann man den weiterführen? Wissen wir nicht. Es hing sehr an seine Person. Mal sehen. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die er auch installiert hat, die in seinem Sinne handeln. Aber ob das so hinhaut, werden wir sehen. Ähnliches ist es mit dem Kader, dass es da eine Fluktuation geben kann. Das ist fast gegeben. Wenn du viel Talent hast, und das ist ja quasi was Besonderes im Hertha-BSC-Kader, dann wird man da auch viel verlieren. Das haben wir vorhin bei Kiel letztlich auch besprochen, wie das eben einfach so eine Normalität ist, dass die besten Spieler dann oft doch leider wieder gehen. Wo ich allerdings so ein komplett großes Fragezeichen habe, ist bei Pahl Darday, den wir schon 30 Mal, ich runde jetzt ab, als Trainer gesehen haben, also in 30 einzelnen Laufzeiten, die er da zuständig war, wo sich auf eine positive Art und Weise nie was verändert hat. Er war immer gleich als Pahl Darday, wo man aber auch manchmal gemerkt hat, so im zweiten Jahr, dass dieses Immer-Gleich-Sein manchmal auch so einen Abnutzungseffekt hat. Und man sich so gedacht hat, ja, haben wir jetzt alles schon mal gehört und den Fußball kennen wir jetzt auch inzwischen. Kann es sein, dass sich auch gerade seine Figur und wie er gesehen wird im Hertha-Umfeld ändert, weil er es eben auch nicht schafft, Hertha aus dieser – na, lethargie ist zu viel, aber aus diesem Schwebezustand heraus zu bekommen. Und das war ja genau seine Kernkompetenz, die er bisher immer drauf hatte. Hol Pahl und er rettet das alles, er kriegt das irgendwie hin und beim Abstieg kam sehen, er hat einfach zu spät geholt.
Na ja, er hat ja schon was geleistet. Also was im Sommer da passiert ist, das war ja wirklich – ich meine, du hast einen Spieler wie Luka Tuzar geholt für 25 Millionen, der ging dann für 1, 2 zum Stadtrivalen. Und dann da aus diesem Haufen – ich meine, er hat im Grunde den Kader fertig gehabt nach drei Spieltagen. Und dann lief das eigentlich super. Und ich glaube, hätten sich dann nicht zum Beispiel sein Sohn verletzt, dann hätte das sich auch jetzt spielerisch etwas weiterentwickeln können. Jetzt bist du halt – es gibt Leute, die stimmen mehr in sich, da, der raus, da, der raus. Im Grunde ist die Person, Pall Dadaj – bei Hertha, der kann sich nichts mehr einreißen. Der könnte morgen zu Union wechseln, als Trainer mit dem Deutscher Meister werden. Das würde ihm nix anhaben, also er hat halt sein Denkmal. Was mich freuen würde, wenn man es mal schaffen würde, sich von ihm jetzt zu trennen. Dass man sagt, okay, wir machen nicht weiter, dann geht er in die Akademie, vielleicht als Akademieleiter, und dann geht es einfach weiter mit einem neuen Trainer. Ich glaube nicht, dass er sich viel kaputt machen kann, aber er wird ein bisschen dünnhäutiger wieder in den Interviews, habe ich das Gefühl. Mit der Medien-Schälte ist die Presse angefangen, hätte vom Aufstieg zu reden. Andererseits läuft auch vieles gut, ich bin jetzt auch vielleicht ein bisschen negativ, aber es gibt zum Beispiel Sachen wie diese interne Doku, die gemacht wird. Also Hertha TV macht in-house eine Doku und die ist ziemlich stark, muss ich sagen. Und die haben jetzt auch angefangen, die letzten Teile als Premiere im Kino zu machen, die waren ausverkauft. Gestern war eine Premiere in Neukölln, da ist dann auch Fabi Reza aufgelaufen. Das ist alles im Verein lief, das ist das erste Mal seit Jahren irgendwie gut, dass du das Gefühl hast, okay, man führt sich zusammen, es ist ein neues Wehgefühl da. Aber du hast jetzt auch – also Kai Bernstein am Anfang hätte eh geendet, jetzt zum Sommer, da wären neue Wahlen gewesen. Du hast immer noch die große Gefahr, dass der Investor irgendwie jemanden da findet, der genehmer gewesen wäre, so wie zum Beispiel Frank Steffel war, dem Lars Windhorst, glaube ich, ganz glücklich gewesen wäre. Also meine große Hoffnung ist, dass die Fans gesehen haben, was geht und sich das nicht mehr wegnehmen lassen. Dass ein neuer Status quo entsteht, so auch ein bisschen wie bei den DFL-Protesten, hast du ja auch gesehen, was die Fans können. Und dass man sich darauf ein bisschen mehr besinnt und versucht, das ein bisschen mehr in den Vordergrund zu bringen und nicht immer nach oben zu gucken. Spielerisch, es gibt großartige Leute. Ich meine, Pascal Clemens, der ist 19 Jahre alt, der hat fast alle Spiele gemacht, egal ob in der Verteidigung oder auf Sechs. Das macht er alles ganz easy, hat, glaube ich, in Hannover ein Tor geschossen. Das ist alles sehr schön. Du hast dann auch ein Kader, der kommt über das Argument, der Kader ist so teuer, der müsste doch eigentlich ganz oben sein. Der Kader hat lauter Altverträge. Kempf zum Beispiel, ich glaube, Kempf ist der bestverdienste Spieler in der zweiten Liga und dann hast du noch ein Kenny hier schon auch. Also alles, was aus der Bo-Bitch-Ära kommt, wird riesen krass alte Verträge haben. Deswegen werden die auch alle wahrscheinlich gehen müssen, auch egal wie gut du siehst. Ein Kenny hat sich super gemacht dieses Jahr, aber irgendwie es gibt keine wirkliche Entwicklung in dem Sinne, dass man es geschafft hat, irgendwas anderes aufzubauen, als ein Pass von hinten links einfach auf Reese und der guckt dann irgendwie. Du hast einen Tabakowitsch, der mal fünf Tore in zwei Spielen macht, aber so richtig lang zusammen geht es nicht. Du hast auf dem rechten Flügel ein bisschen das Problem, du hast einen Martin Winkler, der hat ganz okay angefangen und seitdem ist er irgendwie immer ein bisschen raus. Man weiß nicht so recht, was passiert und du hast dieses Mittelfeldproblem. Also wir haben früher immer in den Erstliga-Jahren davon gesprochen, von der Tore des sechstes Tore, des Todes, halt Doppelsechstes Todes, Fabian Lustenberger und Pierre Schellbrett. Was du da heute auf der Sechs hast, ist es einfach, das war die ganze Zeit auch immer die Achillesferse und deswegen wurden die Spieler auch im Grunde verloren, weil du im Mittelfeld nicht hinterher gekommen bist. Und da sehe ich noch keine so richtige Lösung.
Also auch Pascal Clemens kann das alleine nicht auf seinen Schultern tragen. Ich meine, wie gesagt, die sportliche Situation ist so in der Schwebe. Und dann haben wir ja aber als letztes ein großes Thema, also wir werden natürlich viel über die Mitgliederversammlung noch hören, die dann stattfinden wird in diesem Jahr noch. Aber dann haben wir natürlich noch Triple Seven und deren Einstieg. Da habe ich jetzt schon lange nichts mehr von gehört. Äußern die sich nicht? Bekommt man nicht raus, in welchem Sinne die mit Hertha zusammenarbeiten? Wann gibt es denn endlich die ersten Zugänge aus Genua und so weiter? Also was ist da der Stand?
Also sie setzen sich nicht bei BildTV hin wie Lars Windhorst. Und ich hoffe, dass Spors nicht zu Nius sich setzen wird. Heute kam ein bisschen was, also es gab immer schon, es soll im Sommer so gewesen sein, dass sie gerne gehabt hätten, dass Palldare nicht Trainer wird, sondern bei der Führung damals gelungen Palldare als Trainer durchzusetzen gegen Widerstand des Investors. Sie halten sich relativ zurück. Ich glaube, wir haben einen Spieler verliehen an Standard Lüttich. Das ist, glaube ich, einer der großen, wunderbaren Triple-Seven-Familien. Also sie machen es deutlich besser als Lars Windhorst, was im Grunde auch keine große ist.
Ich bin so schlecht im Zähnen, hätte es trotzdem besser gemacht als Lars Windhorst.
Sie halten sich zurück, aber ich glaube, da wird jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr hinter dem Kulissen ein bisschen Druck gemacht. Andererseits haben wir jetzt einen Weber als Sportdirektor, den ich jahrelang immer nur als Leiter der Akademie kannte. Und ich weiß noch, wie skeptisch wir alle waren. Es gab dann direkt nach dem Rauswurf von Bobic gab es so einen Termin, wo man sich anmelden konnte. 200 Fans wurden zugelassen. Dann saßen die da vorne, Kai, Zecke, Neuendorf und Benny Weber. Und wir haben uns gedacht, okay, was soll es. Aber mittlerweile hat er mit dem, was er hatte, eine super Transferphase hingelegt, was wir bekommen haben für wenig Geld. Du hast einen Tabakobestand, 5 Tore geschossen. Was ich nicht so weiß, was macht Dade aus dem Kader? Du hast ein paar Spiele, die hast du einfach nicht mehr gesehen. Du hast uns mal Treviac, der eigentlich immer ganz okay war. Den sehe ich immer auf dem Spielbogen als mit dabei, aber ich sehe ihn einfach nicht mehr. Dudziak ist schon länger wieder fit. Dudziak war ganz wichtig. Ich glaube, der war vereinzelt. Der kam von Fürz für umsonst, weil er in die Türkei ausgeliehen war. Und dann war er in der Erdbebenzone. Der kam aus dem richtigen Höllen. Der hat uns super toll angefangen. War ganz wichtig, das Spiel ein bisschen zu bewegen. Dann hat er einmal kurz gegen Kiel gespielt, hat fast noch das entscheidende Tor geschossen. Seitdem habe ich ihn nicht mehr gesehen. Dann hast du Karbovnik, den teuersten Transfer, der am Anfang okay war. An dieser linken Seite hast du Karbovnik. Letztes Jahr war er offenbar ein sehr guter Linksverteidiger bei Düsseldorf. Und ein Resa, das muss ja super, großartig laufen, aber irgendwie, der zeigt sich auch nicht mehr so richtig. Das ist schwierig. Am meisten verzweifelt man, dass es einmal ein Barcock ist, der sechs spielt, obwohl er achter oder zehnter ist. Und keiner weiß so richtig, warum. Ich hatte Szenen, wo ich dachte, das geht alles. Und es kann kein Dadeiball mehr. Die Jugendspieler kommen ja auch aus dem – die gewinnen ja fast alle ihre Spiele. Die haben ein Offensivspiel. Das ist nicht mehr dieses Marvin Plattenhardt-Ball kommt. Ich trete drauf, gucke erstmal nach hinten, gebe einen Pass nach hinten. Aber auch dann hast du Leute wie Maximilian Mittelstedt, der jahrelang es nicht schafft, am Plattenhardt vorbeizukommen und jetzt bei Stuttgart zum Nationalspieler wird.
Das tut natürlich weh. Nein. Das heißt, wie ist dein Ausblick? Also Aufstieg dann nächstes Jahr alternativlos. Und das wird dann auch klappen. Zusammen mit Hannover geht ihr rauf.
Und Kiel, hast du ja gesagt. Von daher, du hast ja alle drei Aufsteiger hier sitzen. Das ist ja 2025.
Da wird es dann endlich einer wieder in der Relegation schaffen. Gleich kann sich Kiel an Köln dann rächen. Das ist ja, aber gut, die Relegationsstories, die müssen wir jetzt noch nicht auspacken.
Wir können schon dieses Jahr hoch und dann habt ihr Platz für eins und zwei nächstes Jahr.
Na, siehste, da haben wir es doch. Dann können endlich auch mal, weißt du, erst kann Kiel hoch und dann dürfen die Investorenvereine auch. Das finde ich eigentlich eine schöne Reihenfolge. Muss ich sagen. Und dann gibt es auch kein 50 plus 1 mehr und dann ist...
Ja, Holstein hat ja in der Mitgliederversammlung letztes Jahr 50 plus 1 in die Satzung aufgenommen, nach Wunsch der Fans. Und deswegen, da sind wir nur ganz gut davor.
Ja, gut, aber also 50 plus 1 wackelt mehr als jemals zuvor. Aber ich bin gerade dran, hoffentlich gibt es da irgendwann ein Tribüngespräch dazu. Neugucken, vielleicht kommt mir auch die Realität zuvor, ehrlich gesagt. Das geht jetzt alles sehr, sehr schnell, wie 50 plus 1 gerade vor die Hunde geworfen wird von denjenigen, die 50 plus 1 hochhalten müssten. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Ja, bei uns gibt es aber auch noch die Satzungskommission, noch von Kai Bernstein einberufen. Da ist man dran. Und ich habe auch in diesem DFL-Investorenprozess gesehen. Ich glaube, früher mit einem Ingo Schiller und einem Michael Prez, da hätte Hertha öffentlich gesagt, wir wissen nicht. Und die hatten sofort mit Ja geschrieben. Jetzt sind wir ein klares Nein. Das ist auch schon mal ein großer Fortschritt. Und das ist halt für dich als Fan, was du gerade erlebst, ist der Verein hält zusammen. Es ist wirklich diese Familie und nicht dieses Lalalala-Abschiedskultur. Also ich habe dieses Tribütengespräch gehört und es war hart.
Für das Produkt als Verein war Hannover auch ein klares Nein.
Stimmt, wir haben ja hier die Investoren. Feinde sitzen quasi, die gleichzeitig Investorenvereine sind. Das ist der wunderbare Fußball. Solche Geschichten schreibt dann tatsächlich nur mal der Fußball in dem Sinne. Aber das heißt quasi abschließend, ich habe das Gefühl, Jan, es ist eine Saison in der Schwebe. Viele Dinge nerven, vor allem die Rückrunde. Viele Dinge tun weh. Natürlich, Kai Bernstein und die Ungewissheit, was jetzt kommt, ist auch so. Aber Hertha hat sich schon in diesem relativ kurzen Zeitraum des Wirkens von Kai Bernstein und eben auch von Menschen wie eben Pardada, der später sicherlich eine Rolle, auch Benni Weber, zu sich gefunden. Und das wird jetzt nicht von einer, sagen wir es wie es ist, beschissenen Rückrunde irgendwie rausgerissen, sondern wenn da jetzt nicht was ganz Schlimmes passiert, geht man irgendwie aus dieser Saison raus. Ganz viele Ungewissheiten bleiben, aber man bleibt auch bei sich.
Es hängt halt sehr viel von dieser Mitgliederversammlung ab. Also, dann ist ja die Frage, wer dann Präsident wird. Wenn das etwas investorenfreundlicheres wird, dann kann das alles sehr schnell wieder zurückkippen. Aber im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr ist es wirklich ein – also, wenn wir jetzt den Tod von Kai Beinstein ausklammern würden, wäre es eigentlich ein okayes Jahr. Und ich bin zufällig bei Stadion Check auf den Blog geraten vor ein paar Tagen. Der hatte im Mai geschrieben, als hätte er abgestiegen, weil er wünscht, dass er mal ein ganz ruhiges Jahr im Mittelfeld hat.
Sehr gut. Ja, es sind die kleinen Dinge. Und die muss man sich auch gewöhnen. Woran ich mich nie gewöhnen werde, ist, dass diese Sendungen immer viel zu kurz sind. Aber ich kann auch nichts machen irgendwann. Aber ihr drei, das hat große Freude gemacht, mit euch über eure Vereine zu sprechen. Und auch immer wieder interessant, ich dachte nicht, dass es diesmal so viele Parallelen gibt, aber so ein paar habe ich dann doch erkannt. Und ich glaube, die Hörerinnen und Hörer auch. Also ich danke euch drei sehr herzlich. Ganz herzlichen Dank, Pike. Schön, dass du mal wieder da warst. Herzlichen Dank für den völlig ironiefreien Ansgar. Danke dir.
Immer wieder.
Und danke, Jan. Schön, dass du hier warst im Rasenfunk. Ja, mit euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke ich natürlich auch. Es gibt zwei Dinge, die ich noch abkündigen möchte, bevor ich euch entlasse in die sonstigen Podcasts, die ihr so hören wollt. Das eine ist etwas Persönliches und zwar, wir brauchen ein neues Rasenfunk Headquarter. Ich wurde leider auf Eigenbedarf gekündigt. Drohe Geschichte, kann man auch nichts gegen machen. Bisschen belastend, aber ihr könnt mir dabei helfen. Ich suche jetzt neue Vermieter und ich brauche nette Vermieter auf nette-vermieter-gesucht.de. Da könnt ihr erfahren, was ich suche in München und wo ich suche in München und da kann man mir auch helfen, indem man diese Seite teilt, indem ihr alle euren Kontakte schickt. Wir brauchen irgendjemanden, der einfach sagt, ich will nur einen netten Mieter. Dann verzichte ich vielleicht auch auf den einen oder anderen Euro und dann komme ich ins Spiel. Also geht bitte auf diese Seite nette-vermieter-gesucht.de, jeweils mit einem Minus dazwischen, werde es auch verlinken und dann bedanke ich mich aber natürlich bei euch allen, die meine Miete bisher bezahlen, auch wenn die jetzt exorbitant steigen wird. Und in dieser Folge danke ich FrankyPanky, Michael, Carlito1904, Nina und Alex, René und Lisa R. Sie alle unterstützen uns nicht nur finanziell auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club, sondern sie alle haben sich auch registriert dort. Und deswegen kann ich euch hier nach dem Zufall das Prinzip danken. Und unterstützen könnt ihr uns via PayPal, Kreditkarte, alles Mögliche geht. Jetzt schaltet uns der Zahlungsdienstleister sogar noch klar nach frei, obwohl wir nie danach gefragt haben. Also es gibt wirklich keine Ausreden, es nicht zu tun. Und alles, was wir hier tun, wird von euch finanziert. Und keine Angst, nicht nur meine Miete, auch die Gäste kriegen einen Honorar und so weiter und so fort. In diesem Sinne, Dank für euren Support. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.